this is a this is a series we were
moving into a geometric series then we
looked at yesterday every notice the
problem right if you try and play around
with this guy because of this infinity
thing right we land in some problems
when we try to sum the series does
anyone remember what we actually did
what do we do with this it wasn't many
lines and I was like three or four
minutes okay we multiplied this series
by - why - why not three or four minus
one or excellent so the ratio in between
these is two and the way that we got our
formula for the sum of AGP which was
here's one of the forms and the other
one the way we wrote the derive the
result for the partial sum is we did
this trick we multiplied by the common
ratio right so of course we got this now
in exactly the same way I did the I try
to make s the sum the subject by taking
y2 and subtracting 1 1 that's what we
did right and I'm showing about - s - s
is just yes right and because all of
these terms cancel and you're
subtracting the first line right all you
get is this lone survivor and that's
probably right so I've done this a
number of times as we go through this
topic in the last couple of weeks I said
when you when you deal with infinity
these normal games that we play with
just addition subtraction multiplication
right is very very problematic if only
if only we had a tool that could cope
with things like infinity that could
deal with all the apparent problems oh
wait we do we do have a tool we learn to
in like turn - that is specifically
designed like it was literally invented
to deal with what happens when something
goes to infinity and never ends
what tool is that we call them limits
right so limits this is not the heading
my way but it's the idea limits are our
first surprising connection between this
topic which you have not
to do with calculus right and a
technique which we you know we loved it
so that we could deal with calculus why
specifically what was the particular use
we had for limits to remember yes okay
good
no yes in doing uh if you if you recall
right
wait we had a look at a whole bunch of
like arbitrary limits and how to
simplify them but there was one
particular limit that was really really
important to us
right it's a limited started like this
what wasn't which first principles right
the first principles are first
principles of what what is this thing
it's the it's the gradient of the
tangent at a particular point sir we
used this idea limits to to wrestle
biskits to the ground and we succeeded
okay well we're going to use limits to
take something like this and work with
it okay so you've already got this
written but underneath it I want us to
write this okay we define you can see
I've actually already sort of put this
notation in what I've got up here in my
first three lines and on your worst end
everything there is on this is not a
partial sum anymore neither of these are
purporting to be partial sums right
which is why I don't have an end there
do you see that there's no end because S
sub n implies there are how many terms
in terms right there's oh there's
beginning in an end right but this
doesn't have an end
so therefore what we're going to define
is this term yes what it's equal to is
and we're going to use our limit
notation here okay
it's the limit of the partial sum as n
gets bigger bigger and bigger we have
language for this we would say and
approaches infinity are you okay with
that that's weak and what we're defining
as
s right so this is now kind of a
different creature right this thing here
it's not a partial somebody war it's
imagining
what happens to those partial songs as I
just add more and more and arbitrarily
more terms
okay does that make sense so very subtle
difference good morning please make sure
that you pay attention to when you write
s right which is this thing going to
infinity and when you write now said
which is a partial sum okay you're ugly
bet okay now clearly some partial sums
I'm not going to have a meaningful
result for this limit do you remember
wait sometimes we looked at me looked at
graphs sometimes a limit exists but
sometimes it doesn't right for example
this is quickly of one on in okay or if
you like because remember just like with
Sigma notation in limits these are all
dummy variables yeah they can they'll
disappear depending of the limit what's
happening here this is the limit as X
approaches infinity of 1 over X it's
that familiar hyperbola right
what's it equal to it's equal to 0 great
and do you have a picture in your head
for what that graph looks like so there
you go and you have this asymptotic
behavior ok but we saw there were all
kinds of questions actually where the
limit as for instance and approaches
infinity of some kind of function like
say insulin something as simple as that
no limit exists like this thing is just
a parabola right it's not approaching
anything it's not approaching anything
and so this limit it doesn't have a
value like there's no sensible way to
say okay
just like the limit of this is zero
that's where I'm going well where is
this going and it's like well he's he's
never gonna stop anywhere
he's never approaching anything ok so
we're gonna add some language on to this
which doesn't make so much sense in this
context but it makes more sense in our
context up here with series ok we're
gonna call this guy here where the limit
goes to what an actual value ok we're
going to call this converging you know
what converging is right it's when
things go towards
something inexorably unstoppably they're
all approaching certain things whereas
something like this will what's the
opposite of the word competitive
divergent divergent this is something
which is not approaching anything
meaningful in how many times it's just
blowing up right and whatever value of n
you put in you guys it gets big up the
limit just gets bigger bigger bigger the
limit doesn't exist so when you have a
look at a series like say this first one
that I've got up here okay
clearly this is in the second category
you see that as I put in larger and
larger n is just blow it up it's getting
big it's not it's not coming to any
particular point okay whereas if I can
find a series that is converging on
something as I look at the partial sums
and is getting closer and closer and
closer then I can find the limit and
that's what I defined to be the sum of
the entire series does that make sense
okay just keep in mind that's what we
define to be mathematician didn't have
to define it this way and so if you feel
a bit I can talk about some of the
results that we're going to arrive at
later today um keep in mind it's about
like I want this we want this to be
equal to this this is the answer that
makes the most sense so that's how we
define it okay so now I want to think
about what kind of series will do this
what kind of issues converge maybe I
should ask this question why is it that
this series we ran up here why is it
that it diverges
what about the series makes it diverge
yeah on the step sequence gathers its
terms from gets exponentially larger as
it moves
logically number of terms yeah fantastic
um exponentially larger it's funny
because you've got what what are these
survivor emote them okay in terms of the
powers right there there's a zero and
then to the one and then 2 squared too
cute to the four etc okay I guess you
could argue whether that's more like a
polynomial that makes better job but
that's okay it gets really big really
fast and it gets bigger faster as it
grows okay so that's the problem in
other words it's all about our right
that's what makes a series or grow yeah
or in this case the common ratio of
course is it's two in this value in this
series right now let's just underneath
you think all right what kinds of other
series are gonna have this problem
because we need to know what to avoid
right for example if I make this smaller
suppose I made it like I don't know say
one and a half okay let's try one little
what kind of series would I get if I
were one and a half I'd start with one
come in what's my password
we know what a how squared is right it's
uh yeah yeah because it's three over two
it's nine right we might as well
actually write it as 9 over 4 because
that will make it a little easier to do
with the power okay what's the next tab
going to be it's 3 over 2 and on cubing
right so that's going to be 27 or 8 and
I think the next one will be a 1 or Z 16
and I'll do one more just so you can see
it okay so there's my series now clearly
you can see even though I made the ratio
small do I not have the same problem I
still had the same problem this thing is
still blowing up it's still diverging I
think with me what's the what's the
smallest I could possibly make my ratio
so it's two boys up so still get
bigger and bigger and bigger forever
yeah okay so so five or if I have one
and a half or if I have like one point
zero zero zero zero one or even if I
have one let's think about that series
oh yeah if the ratio were just one but
that will still be GP because I can do
my test turn three or ten to turn to
your turn one it was still passed right
once that series look like now I know
it's trivial it's a string but it's
still diverging isn't it like it's not
going towards a value like one on N is
going towards a value okay so this this
is my particular point right this is my
my end point where if I'm 1 or anything
above I'm in trouble
okay I'm in trouble now as we will
discover in a second that's not the only
place that there are problems I'll let
you ever think maybe you've worked out
already where there's where else they're
hobos but let's stop that you have
problems now and thinking about place
where it works okay